so we're going to be signing today and
registering national emergency and it's
a great thing to do because we have an
invasion of drugs invasion of gangs
invasion of people and it's unacceptable
and by signing the national emergency
something signed many times by other
presidents many many times President
Obama in fact we may be using one of the
national emergencies that he signed
having to do with cartels criminal
cartels it's a very good emergency that
he signed and we're going to use parts
of it in our dealings on cartels so that
would be a second national emergency but
in that case it's already in place and
what we won't really want to do is
simple it's not like it's complicated
very simple we want to stop drugs from
coming into our country we want to stop
criminals and gangs from coming into our
country nobody's done the job that we've
ever done I mean nobody's done the job
that we've done on the border and in a
way what I did by creating such a great
economy and if the opposing party got in
this economy would be down the tubes you
know I hear a lot of people say oh well
but maybe the previous administration
let me tell you the previous
administration it was heading south and
it was going fast we would have been
down to the tubes the regulations were
strangling our country unnecessary
regulations by creating such a strong
economy you just look at your television
to see what's going on today it's
through the roof
what happens is more people want to come
so we have far more people trying to get
into our country today then probably
we've ever had before and we've done an
incredible job in stopping them but it's
a massive number of people if we had the
wall it would be very easy we would make
up for the cost of the wall just to the
cost of the fact that I would
be able to have fewer people we wouldn't
need all of this incredible talent some
of whom are sitting in the first row you
wouldn't need all of this incredible
talent we would get we would get
thousands of law enforcement people
including Border Patrol you put them in
different areas you have them doing
different things
law enforcement of border patrol and I
want to thank law enforcement and I want
to thank Border Patrol and I want to
thank ice ice is abused by the press and
by the Democrats and by the way we're
going to be taking care of ice you know
we talked about the the new bill we're
gonna be taking care of ice they wanted
to get rid of ice and the bill is just
the opposite of that a lot of good
things happen so that's the story we
want to have a safe country Iran on a
very simple slogan make America great
again if you're gonna have drugs pouring
across the border if you're gonna have
human traffickers pouring across the
water in areas where we have no
protection in areas where we don't have
a barrier then very hard to make America
great again